hey friends how's it going welcome back
to deep dive this episode is a little
bit different because we're talking all
about the topic of breath work what the
hell is breath work i had no idea which
is why i interviewed mike mayer who's
the uk expert on the topic of breath
work he's worked with and interviewed
dozens of people who specialize in
improving i didn't realize this was a
thing apparently the way that we breathe
by default on the way that most of us
kind of find ourselves breathing day to
day is kind of wrong which is quite
interesting because i thought that hey
i've been breathing perfectly fine my
whole life like how bad can it be but
apparently like when we breathe wrong in
terms of either breathing too much
breathing through a little breathing
through our mouth that's something i do
a lot apparently that's really bad all
of that can contribute to things like
increased blood pressure reduce quality
of life and apparently even increase
your risk of heart disease further down
the line and apparently breathwork is
this active meditation where we
consciously alter our breathing patterns
to get outcomes like helping us relax
regulate our stress levels raise our
energy increase our immune system
function changing our state of
consciousness or even calming our
nervous system allegedly to be honest i
was pretty skeptical about the whole
thing but this conversation with mike
has changed the way that i approach
breathing i also read the book breath by
james nestor which is excellent and also
kind of helped me realize the perils of
breathing badly um but that's all the
stuff that we're going to cover in in
this week's conversation on deep dive so
i hope you enjoy this discussion with
breathwork coach mike mayer what is what
is breathwork and is it a scam okay oh
wow plenty help um so first of all i
want to say that i adopt a whiteboard
mentality to everything i'm sure we'll
get stuck into the back yeah the
backstory and all that sort of jazz
later um is it a scam there might be
elements of it potentially like with
anything there's a scam but i like to
use the term now breath play that's my
breath play so we should be playing with
our breath okay and i'm hoping over the
next period of time that we're talking
i'll try and demystify some of it for
you because actually there's quite a lot
of science that sits behind breath work
or breath play but the simplest thing i
would say is you've got two
areas of breath work so i'm going to try
now to simplify breath work for you i'm
going to simplify every breathing
exercise that's ever existed okay in two
ways um so here we go so uh we breathe
25 000 times a day something like that
some of us may be 30 35 000 25 000
breaths a day we're all doing that um
and then we've got all these different
breathing exercises that people talk
about
and so there's two categories number one
i breathe less than i need so that would
be one group of exercises and that's
what i would really like to talk about
today functional breathing i'm going to
get out that route so i breathe less so
an example of that would be
alternate nostril breathing so i'm
sitting here right now breathing maybe
i'm doing 15 breaths a minute
and all of a sudden i'm going to cap my
right nostril i'm going to breathe in
really slowly
and out really slowly
now i've capped the airflow through my
nose so already it's half an austral
heart one nostril rather than two and
i'm breathing slower than i need and
that's got a whole load of benefits
which we'll get stuck into okay now
there's the other side of breath work i
breathe more than i need
hyperventilation exercises benefits
there
maybe some people would call some
woo-woo stuff there as well i've had
some profound experiences in there
but what i would like people to take
them away from from this conversation
it's we need to get our foundation of
breathing right because
i believe we've lost our way how to
breathe okay we don't breathe the way
nature has intended us to breathe okay
and the good news is our body wants to
breathe correctly and we can find out
how to do it quite quickly as well okay
what what what do you mean by breathe
breathe correctly like i've i've been
breathing my whole life i'm sitting here
i haven't died yet yes my nose always
feels a bit blocked and i'm definitely a
mouth breather but like you know yeah so
what so what yeah yeah what's the point
is it's uh yeah i've been breathing my
whole life yeah
and uh when i was i was talking to my
girlfriend's mum was like what's he
doing on youtube what's this thing
breathing breathe out everyone's doing
that yeah so so you know there's a
wonderful writer called dr chris ryan he
wrote a book called sex at dawn and he
wrote another one called civilized to
death which i highly recommend and the
front cover of that book is a chimpanzee
i think he's got t-shirt on he's sitting
in a bad posture with a cigarette
he's got his iphone out and a can of
coke
and
we're that chimpanzee we are not
designed to be sitting
16 hours a day in poor posture chronic
stress emails coming in you know sitting
straight
so so we're living very not how our
ancestors used to live and so of course
if i'm in a compressed position
and i'm stressed there's a very good
chance that i've gone to mouth breathing
because mouth breathing is stressful
breathing and we'll get into that i'm
probably in a bad posture so my
diaphragm's a bit locked not moving
properly so as a productivity uh guru
man uh person um i would say that we're
not breathing as efficiently as we
should be
and that's the key to this is efficient
breathing we're not being efficient
right now why does efficient breathing
matter okay isn't the whole point of
breathing to you know oxygen into
bloodstream carbon dioxide out of
bloodstream
and
the body figures the rest out yes yes
but there's a nuance to this okay where
we go down the path so let's uh let's
talk about the nose first of all the
nose is is a wonderful organ that sits
on your face this beautiful schnoz that
breathes um we've got all these
wonderful hairs that's sitting there and
they filter all the dust and rubbish out
of the air if the air is too cold it's
going to warm up the air for us if it's
too hot it's going to cool it down it's
going to humidify it it's going to put
pressure into the air because when i
breathe through the mouth that big old
pipe it just it just comes in really
quick yeah but when i breathe through
the nose i'm breathing a bit slower
so pace which we'll get into as well is
really important so the nose does all
these wonderful things and it also does
it releases something called nasal
nitric oxide are you familiar with that
uh vaguely it's like a vasodilator or
something it is a basodilator so it
helps open up all the smooth tissues and
around the body um i think it one
molecule of the year 1992.
um but but um that is produced through
your nose
and if you hum which will be a breathing
exercise we'll do later it produces more
of it so let's think about what we've
just covered off there warming and
cooling of the air uh moisturizing of
the air pressurizing the air sterilizing
the air through nasal nitric oxide all
of these things happen here you don't
get any of that through the mouth it's
sterilizing the air there's nasal nitric
oxide it kills bacteria it kills
bacteria so if you want a bit of
protection from airborne issues that are
going on in today's society you get zero
protection if you are using your mouth
if you're using your nose that you have
got all of these protections your nose
is designed for breathing your mouth is
designed for kissing and eating which i
quite like okay
so why
i mean i'm i'm very much a mouth
breather and i i realized this when i
started doing youtube videos and i
started doing vlogs filming myself yeah
and i'd be like
i would look at myself and i would have
this sort of
at all times where i'm like hunched over
a belly sticking out and i just had no
idea that i was doing this by the way if
you if anyone anyone's listening to this
on the podcast version
i would consider checking it out on the
youtube version because i guess we're
going to be talking about breath and
like exercises and stuff where seeing it
visually might also help but we'll do
our best to describe things as we're
going along for the listeners but i had
this very much
kind of posture with my mouth open and i
also realized when i started doing the
podcast that i was looking back at the
footage and i was like why is my mouth
hanging open like an idiot all the time
like what's going on there um but at the
same time as a mouth breather i still
have survived so like what are the
what are the kind of downsides of mouth
breathing other than all the because yes
there's all these all these
things that the nose does for you but i
feel i'm operating at reasonable
capacity just by breathing through the
mouth yeah yeah okay so uh i too was a
chronic mouth breather until i found out
and here's the thing what's going to
happen for you now would be a
perspective shift because next time you
go to the gym
oh my god everyone needs to shut them
out you'll just see it we all go around
with our mouths open so um the problems
are and it's a bold claim you are
literally starving yourself of oxygen by
breathing through your mouth and i'll
explain a bit of the science behind it
um so what's going on here so oxygen
comes in with the air and we breathe co2
out co2 is a waste gas we've heard that
term before um and interestingly i was
watching you've got some wonderful study
with me videos and i was watching one
the other day putting on the background
you know just to just crack on with my
work and you're looking at the oxygen
dissociation curve yeah and bore effect
and that sort of thing so if i break
this down to a really simple way um
homeostasis we want to be balanced our
nose is designed for breathing our mouth
isn't it by the way emergency fantastic
backup if you break your nose you get
into trouble or there's that
saber-toothed tiger everyone keeps
talking about in the wilderness we've
got this fantastic extra valve we can
open up but actually it's there for that
emergency situation
so when you are mouth breathing
you're blowing off too much co2 so too
much is coming out because the pressure
is here
and you're breathing at a nice slow rate
and we'll talk about pace as well and so
you're breathing out too much co2 now
that is also it works like a vasodilator
as well so when you don't have enough
co2 in your body everything starts to
constrict and it gets tighter
and here's the other thing
so in our plasma in our blood in our red
blood cells we've got hemoglobin
um
in each red blood cells around 270
million uh hemoglobin and in each of
those it can hold four molecules so four
oxygen or four co2 so i like to call
that the the hemoglobin taxi so four
passengers get him now those taxes drive
around the body and you know if i pick
up a
really heavy bottle and i start to
you know do some you know some curves
this muscle is going to start to get
warm you know it's using extra energy
it's probably using more than my legs
which aren't really moving and so
there's a presence of of co2 there and
your body wants to deliver some oxygen
and then take the co2 away
if you have blown off too much co2 then
the presence of co2 is lower it is
harder for the oxygen to get into the
places it needs to get to what's known
as the affinity is now stronger the
oxygen doesn't want to leave the
hemoglobin and so it's not getting out
you're no longer an efficient breather
you're making it harder for your body to
get oxygen to the places it needs to get
to we are going to take a little quick
break from the podcast to introduce the
sponsor of this podcast which is
curiosity stream if you haven't heard by
now curiosity streams is the world's
leading documentary streaming
subscription platform founded by john
hendricks who's the founder of the
discovery channel and on curiosity
stream they've got hundreds of really
high quality high budget documentaries
covering all sorts of things from
science and technology to history and
ancient civilizations to food and
medicine and meditation like all of the
stuff in between now the really cool
thing about curiosity stream is that
they support independent creators and so
there is this service called nebula
which you might have heard of it's an
independent streaming platform that's
run by me and a bunch of other creators
and on nebula we can put content like
videos and behind the scenes and long
form longer form stuff without worrying
about things like the youtube algorithm
and so for example in nebula i have a
bunch of exclusive content that you
won't find anywhere else we actually
have the original season zero of the
deep dive podcast which started off as
like remote zoom live streams during the
pandemic and that is only available on
nebula you won't find it anywhere else
so if you enjoy the sorts of
conversations we have on deep dive you
might like to see you know a whole year
before we started this podcast properly
once the pandemic stopped what sort of
conversations i was having with people
on zoom i've also got a series of videos
in nebula called workflow which is where
i deep dive into some of my favorite
productivity tools and on nebula you
also get early ad-free access to my
videos and videos from a bunch of other
creators that you might be familiar with
like thomas frank and tom scott and
legal eagle and lindsey ellis and the
really cool thing is that because
curiosity stream love supporting
independent creators we've got another
bundle deal which is that if you sign up
for an account on curiosity stream you
actually get free access to nebula
bundled with that so if you head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive then for less than 15 a year you
can get full access to curiosity streams
incredible library of documentaries and
also free access to all of the stuff on
nebula bundled with that so head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive to get the bundle deal so thank you
curiosity stream for sponsoring this
episode yeah this is
reminding me of like first geophysiology
where it's like co2 contributes to the
acidity of the blood and
in one of the directions whether i can't
remember whether blood becomes more
acidic or less acidic uh the curve
you've got the shift the bore effect the
shift to the right or whatever and then
it's harder for oxygen to be released
um so you're saying okay
so if we're breathing through our mouths
then a because of the fact that we
breathe more frequently through our
mouths and b because of the fact that
there's less pressure of air going out
because the way gases are exchanged is
based on kind of partial pressure
differentials we are therefore blowing
off more co2 than we probably should
compared to breathing through our nose
yes that is causing the bore
oxygen dissociation curve to shift in
the direction that means that we are
more likely to be somewhat starving our
muscles of oxygen the affinity is too
strong yeah we can't get the oxygen out
now there's more layers to this so um
when you blow off co2
you so so you have sensors in the back
of your your brain
chemoreceptors and what they're doing is
the body is this wonderful machine you
know it's it's detecting how much co2
is in the blood and there'll be a base
level for all of us now the wonderful
thing is if i get to a situation where i
start running or i'm scared or what have
you um and the co2 starts to rise or i
hold my breath it's probably because i
hold my breath co2 starts to rise
um the chemoreceptors go oh no we we've
got a problem here the co2 is going up
let's send a signal to the brain to the
lungs we need to stop breathing faster
quicker now you're going to feel an air
hunger and that is the co2 rising
because many people think when i hold my
breath
um and i feel that need to breathe oh
it's because i'm running out of oxygen
but if we put on a pulse oximeter you're
probably between 95 98 full of oxygen
you hold your breath maybe because 92
you're full of oxygen so it's not your
body run out of oxygen it's the co2
that's rising and there is a later
stimulus i believe that says the oxygens
are in that and there'll be another
impulse to breathe i believe that's much
much later and so what's happening here
is we've all got this co2
baseline
which is flexible this is the problem
and a good thing it's a flexible bass
line so right now if i was you know a
mouth breath in my entire life it might
be that when my co2 rises to this point
the signals start to say you need to
breathe a bit faster because we're a bit
worried
if i'm chronically mouth-breathing
blowing off too much co2 i have a new a
new baseline it starts to be at a lower
level
and then there's this thing which is
like a vicious circle because i now feel
air hunger at a lower level
i'm more likely to breathe quickly and
maybe breathe through my mouth and guess
what that's gonna do it's gonna it's
gonna lower it down a bit more and so
this is the the cycle most of us are
stuck in and this problem relates to how
we sleep how we exercise and how we work
rest you know and do the things during
the day and they all affect each other
so if you are a uh mouth breather in the
gym there's a good chunk of mouth
breathing at night if your mouth
breathing at night there's a good chance
your mouth breathing when you're sitting
and working and the three things go
together and just going back to your
point about you seeing yourself on the
camera um i i too have had that
and uh i don't think this is a very fair
thing but if you go on google and type
in mouth breather the the and i'm not
calling you this or me it's a stupid
person and if you look at a picture of a
village idiot
yeah they're normally like that so we've
known that this is a problem for a very
very uh long time and in fact um there's
been several reports of this um i think
in kenya and other places where they
would give young children a a cup of
water
and they'd hold the water and they'd
have to run for 10 miles and at the end
of it to pass the test they had to spit
the water out the right amount of water
and the whole reason that was designed
is to make you be a functional nose
breather not business
because another
issue with uh nose breathing versus
mouth breathing um i believe it's a 42
increase in
moisture comes out of your mouth if
you're
blowing onto a mirror or something like
that yeah so i'm sorry i'm going off in
a few different tangents here but in in
essence we don't want to uh lower our
tolerance to co2 we want to increase it
and the good news is we can do that with
breathing exercises and education okay
so
in a nutshell we should not breathe
through our mouth we should breathe
through our nose
and we should not breathe as frequently
as we are we should breathe less
frequently because
we want to have the right level of
carbon dioxide in our blood rather than
an artificially low level of carbon
dioxide in our blood because
the right level of carbon dioxide in our
blood leads to us
the hemoglobin letting go of oxygen more
readily
ergo our muscles and our brain and every
tissue in our body will be more
effective because it's now got the
appropriate amount of oxygen rather than
less oxygen yes
okay interesting um there's one yes
that's worth caveat in here as well
because when i first learnt of this i
was like oh my god i can never breathe
through my mouth again i need to breathe
through my nose all the time because
mouth breathing is really bad and what
this is what puts people into like so if
you're watching this or listen to this
right now this gives you like the extra
bit that a lot of people don't get there
is a huge difference between how i
breathe 25 000 times a day and a
breathing exercise
and we have to know that this
distinguishment is there because there
are some wonderful mouth breathing
exercises that are out there that have
specific qualities for example even just
a sigh
we sigh when we're stressed and we sigh
when we're relaxed and so you might
think oh i shouldn't do that because a
size i'm losing all that moisture and my
mouth breathing and so what we want to
do is we want to create an environment
where we are nasal breathing 99 of the
day but we can still play with some of
the breathing exercises that are out
there
so a few months ago i read the book
breath by james nestor or rather listen
to the audiobook
and basically every single chapter in
that book talks about how mouth
breathing is like you know
the coming of satan
kinda like there's all of these negative
effects of mouth breathing and he kind
of talks about how
mouth breathing is bad for your jawline
mouth breathing is bad for like
basically basically everything
imaginable um
is that is that legit is mouth breathing
like actually killing us as james nestor
would potentially have us believe
you know you you look at the experiment
he did where he bunged his nose up with
two ear plugs for 10 days he looked
really bad at the end of those 10 days i
think very quickly within the first day
or so his blood pressure had gone up x
amount of points um his sleep was
impacted and then i think he said you
know something like 30 the american
population are breathing like this all
the time and then when he took those ear
plugs out of his nose him and anders
olsen i've interviewed both of them
actually um when he took those earplugs
out of his nose i get i think it was
within a matter of hours his blood
pressure had started to come back down
again and started to feel more himself
so again is it is it that bad if it's a
breathing exercise i would say no go go
have some fun with the breathing
exercises but the thing is if most of us
are chronically hyperventilating all the
time we need to get that foundation
fixed first before we stop playing with
the sexy stuff with the big breathing
exercises because that's the stuff
that's going to make sure that we're in
a better place because if you take for
example you know like wim hof breathing
which is 30 big breaths in and then a
pause
that is known as a stressor it's like
going to the gym you're stressing
yourself out and there's some benefits
to that but if you're already stressed
because you've been mouth breathing
all day i think it's the right thing for
you then to go and do some more
hyperventilation i think we need to do
it the other way let's get our baseline
right let's get it secure and then once
it's in a good place we can then start
to play with it okay
so um let's say someone someone watching
or listening to this is like all right
cool i'm sold i want to do this nose
breathing rather than mouth breathing
thing
are there any
are there any tangible benefits they
would get within a reasonable amount of
time or is it like i don't know taking
supplements where it's like oh i know i
probably should do this just so my body
is b12 levels are a baseline but i'm not
really going to notice
a real difference yeah yeah well by the
way i feel like that about turmeric i've
been taking tumor for two years what am
i doing here with this bloody tune break
um so so i i was a chronic mouth
breather and there are some measurements
that you can do so one of them is um
what patrick mcewen the author of the
auction advantage calls maximum uh
breathlessness test so what that is that
is you because it's always good to
measure isn't it you wanna be able to
measure and track your things and so
what you do is you do a normal breath in
normal breath out you cap and then you
walk
and you count them steps you can walk
and you make a note of that
and another one is you do a breath in
breath out hold and you wait till the
first impulse to breathe happens and
that gives you two numbers so you can
start to track that but let's talk about
what are some of the benefits um and i
think it's about flipping on its head
sometimes so what are the problems
because
here's the thing you know i um i like a
bit of grounding i saw a documentary
about grounding how important it is that
our body touches the earth this is a
whole other conversation you know we're
the first animal that's removed our body
from the planet which is really bad you
know put insulation on our shoes um and
actually you can measure the the kind of
um
electromagnetic static in your body uh
when you touch the earth it kind of
falls down and blood moves better it's a
wonderful documentary um but we're these
people that that um
kind of expect a big benefit but
actually a lot of us bringing us back to
baseline to be not to be that chimpanzee
with a can of coke with a poor posture
it's more about well let's just get us
to how nature intended us to be as
opposed to oh there's loads and loads
i'm going to feel like i'm superman well
you might get some of that but if you're
a very poor breather you might not even
know what good breathing feels like
until you do it i drive people mad
because when i'm breathing when i'm
talking i'll i'll take a normal breath
in through the nose now to carry on the
conversation um because i want to keep
that kind of uh good habits going so
some benefits then so let's let's break
some of this down so um there are some
breathing exercises that can improve
your heart rate variability and some
studies on that so there's one breathing
exercise called coherence breathing
um and that heart rate variability is
the the gap between the beats and they
say that they're kind of the variability
of those beats kind of signifies like
good health
sleep is a huge one so probably my
favorite benefit of good breathing i
know you've done mouth taping
and
if you are mouth breathing in the night
which so many of us are because remember
if we're mouth breathing in the gym and
mouth breathing while we're recording
videos and all that sort of stuff and we
talk all day we might be talking all day
and doing different things then there's
a good chance that you might be going to
mouth at some point in the night
now what does that what's the problem
with that well you're never going to get
into the deeper levels of sleep if
you're a mouth breather
and then we know then that poor sleep is
associated with increased risk of
diabetes cancers high blood pressure
you know i before i mouth taped i was a
frequent weir in the night and i just
thought that was normal and then the
minute i started matter is i'm not going
for a wee anymore i'm like what's going
on there and it's because our body is
releasing the right amount of kind of
hormones and suppressing the feelings of
going to the toilet and that sort of
thing and you get a better night's sleep
and be interesting to know your thoughts
on how you experienced it because for me
it took me a couple of months it was so
bloody unnatural to have something on my
mouth i would rip it off but i
persisted with it and now my sleep is is
better i wake up more refreshed i don't
have a dry mouth and so sleep you know
in itself if i just said look i've got
this magical pill for you here that's
going to help you sleep better and it's
going to reduce all the risks associated
with sleep or how much does that pill
i'd love to take that and it might be
able to improve your heart rate
variability and it's going to be able to
lower your blood pressure um and uh
we've not gone to diaphragm yet but
diaphragmatic breathing could help with
lower back issues it could help with
digestive issues so there's a whole host
of other mechanical issues which we can
get into uh because our diaphragm's not
moving properly as well and again we
want to be a functional efficient
breather
okay so plenty of benefits of
nose breathing and i yeah i mean i still
take my mouth
to er to this day i don't do it on days
like if for example i'm staying over at
my mom's place and i forget to take my
3m surgical tape then i'm like oh okay
cool i guess i'm not mouth taping
tonight but i do find that on days i
don't know i don't know if this like i i
need to actually track the data on this
properly but
i do find that on days where i have to
tape my mouth properly and wake up
having not ripped it off i just feel
like it's a bit of a faff take it off
for like getting away with like mustache
and beard and stuff yeah once i've done
that i feel like oh i'm actually i
actually feel pretty rested tonight yeah
and i did i i did like you know i did
this 30 day mouth taping video and i
looked at the hour ring and tried to
track the numbers it didn't really yield
anything particularly significant but
i mean
i still do it and i feel like the
benefit of just not waking up with a dry
mouth plus the fact that i've read this
book and you know
vaguely looked into breathwork a little
bit and and see that okay breathing
through nose well at night seems to have
a lot of benefits
sticking a piece of tape on your mouth
is a magic pill basically to
force yourself to breathe more through
your nose
um one issue that i have just while
we're on the mouth breathing breathing
breathing topic is that i often find my
nose is quite blocked especially if i've
got like a girl like a cold or something
and you know when i was younger i used
to think oh i can't breathe as
efficiently through my nose as i can
through my mouth therefore there is
something wrong with my nose like is
that something that that you
you hear often yeah so um
some people have to have surgery on on
their nose um again i i i'm trained as
an oxygen advantage and pateko breathing
coach so so these are um
areas where we focus on let's breathe
less than we need and so patrick mcewen
who wrote a couple of books in those
areas he says if you can breathe through
your nose for a minute then you can
breathe through your nose for the rest
of your life and he's been looking at
this for sort of 20 years and so um
there is a nose on blocking exercise and
if you've come across this we can do
this when we jump into it um and that
will give you a bit of a bit of uh
relief um but it's use it or lose it as
well if you've come off a day of mouth
breathing and you've not really been
using that nose fully um when you come
to go right i'm going to tape up my
mouth now it might be a bit stuffy
because it's not been been used and so
you could do a breathing exercise to
kind of open it up a little bit
and then once it's open in theory it
should stay open now colds can affect it
asthma can affect her and you know uh
surgical interventions might sometimes
be needed and he obviously would speak
to a medical professional about that but
i think for the vast majority of people
we
we didn't have a very good breath
education i don't know about you at
school no one sat me down and said
breathe through your nose shut your
mouth you know i know in some places i
think it was in mexico they give you a
tap on the back of the head i think if
you if you're in school and you're
breathing through your mouth and same in
poland where my girlfriend's from they
told you you know you shut your mouth um
but we didn't really get that education
and we copy poor role models and
everybody else is doing it and we're not
using our diaphragms properly and so
it's no wonder that we've got this issue
where our noses are a bit stuffy because
we don't really use them as much as we
should do okay so it sounds like nose
breathing breathing properly breathing
less potentially helps us get back to
baseline
um there are other claims that people
say about breath work um i've like
vaguely come across some of the wim hof
stuff but i haven't researched it
extensively where he talks about how
kind of discovering the breathing thing
helped i don't know cure his depression
or was to that effect
there are i know that breathing is a
huge part of all of the like pretty much
every ancient tradition where
there are allegedly benefits for it
people say that breathing in a certain
way gives you psychedelic experiences
beyond the breathing properly gets you
to baseline
what are the other like
actual i guess
evidence-based benefits of breathing
and
like how do we distinguish those from
the potential hype around breathing
which may not necessarily be true yeah
yeah okay so this would put us into i
breathe more than i need category and
we'll have a little chat about that now
so um so my breathwork journey started
in 2016 i i've just gone through a bit
of a split up in a relationship and i
kept hearing this name wim hof wim hof
over and over again um a big fan of joe
rogan podcast i finally listened to a
podcast i thought this guy's incredible
and crazy at the same time and i did
some googling and he had a retreat in
poland this is december 2016. yeah um so
for people who haven't come across one
house can you do a little yeah okay of
course yeah thank you so so uh the dutch
iceman um i think he's broken 26 world
records
he would spend for example his time in a
box of ice and uh you know i think he
did two hours in a box of ice um
he has a bit of a tragic back story
where his partner passed away she took
her own life um and and he used kind of
cold and breathing as a way to deal with
um some of the grief that happened there
and then he created what's called the
wim hof method um which involves
cold exposure and breathing with a
mindfulness element to it
and you combine all those things
together and that was the retreat that i
went on he's got world records for like
hanging from a balloon with one finger
and
running through a desert um with no
water doing a marathon and going up
everest in his shorts and all these
these wonderful things that make you
think oh my god that doesn't seem real
to me yeah and i think he's like well
one thing i remember being struck by
with his story is that he's very cool
with scientists poking and prodding him
and measuring his blood levels and like
doing like yes scientific studies and
stuff yeah which is unusual because most
woo-woo type people yes would be like oh
well it's not going to work if you
measure it whereas this guy say yeah
come at me with all your instruments
yeah it's and it's all good yeah he has
he has a wonderful one about being
injected with a poison and he starts
doing his huffing and puffing breathing
technique and when most people start to
get sick he didn't get sick and he's i
can replicate that with like 20
strangers and he did and i think he did
it again with 40 strangers um
and that is to do with i believe i
haven't read that for a while it's to do
with the adrenaline that's getting
released through this breathing
technique so if i just explain a bit
about the the breathe more than i need
stuff because it is very exciting yeah
sorry i interrupted you in the middle of
your story so you said 2016. you listen
to an episode of joe rogan you discover
wim hof yeah and you're like this guy it
seems interesting
what happens okay yeah so i
go by myself to poland um by the way you
know i've never done anything like this
my background's corporate
i'm very much
what you see is what exists there's
nothing else out there
and so i was very skeptical but also
very drawn to this and again i had this
kind of freedom because i've been in a
relationship for 12 years and and so
something like oh this just feels like
the right thing to do so anyway i go out
there
there's 60 of us in three little cohorts
um and we'd all get in the structure
each and you're with wim the entire time
this guy that i've seen in the podcast
he's got a wonderful vice documentary
had breakfast with him several times
just sitting opposite and picking his
brains um and he would teach you his his
breathing technique and he go off
this is december time now you're going
into these absolutely freezing pools and
lakes and stuff so anyway on the first
proper night of the course we go to
wim's house he's got a little house he's
got a big hotel in the house and he's
got this
dodgy ice bath like i remember his
girlfriend time saying if you slip
you'll break your neck and i was like
jesus christ and so we've got this big
ice bath he cracked the ice off it's
completely pitched black out there
people got mobile phones to kind of show
you where to go in and he's got sauna
inside and so it's like right get in
let's get you in the cold and i i can't
even get in the swimming pool at this
point if it's too cold i used to go to
tenerife as a kid and couldn't get in
the salt pool because it was too cold
that was the reason i wanted to do this
so anyway i went in
um
jumped straight back out again and i was
like i need to go home this is
ridiculous i can't do this and i've been
thinking i've wasted all this money and
all this time and i just sat in the
sauna and people i've been here three
times i've been in four times i just
felt like a real piece of garbage and
then i don't know just something just
like just go back and do it one more
time
and if you hate it then you can leave
and i was like okay so i was having this
conversation i go back in and the guy is
just saying to me relax relax and my
shoulders just came down and i think he
said something like imagine he's
slipping into a warm bath and so i went
into the ice up to my neck and i did
just relax it's like good you've got it
you've nailed it so suddenly i'm in this
it's you know minus five minus six
outside i'm in this water and i'm
completely relaxed it's like this is
ridiculous how is this possible
and then we go on to do the breathing
exercises
and again i'm very analytical
bit atheist not really sure what's going
on
um we're huffing and puffing and we're
doing it for
45 minutes maybe an hour and so we're
doing 30 breaths then we do a retention
so what's happening is this while you're
in the ice this is no no two second
things yeah very very dangerous to do in
the water so we're back in the the hotel
now so you're doing 30 breaths you've
blown off all that co2
and then you're holding your breath and
you can hold your breath for bloody ages
because if you remember from the co2 uh
chemo receptors osteo co2 is so low so
even if i've got a low base line it's
going to take a while for my co2 to
build back up again
and we kept doing that and
i'm telling the story of a story of a
story now ally but i had some of the
most profound
feelings and effects of my life i saw
colours i saw images i um had a weird
conversation with a being and it was it
was very very simple it was just oh i'm
so glad you found us and i've never done
any plant medicines or anything like
that so i know people talk about
ayahuasca and different things
and they've described similar feelings
um
and after it was all over i was just in
the flood of tears and there were 20 of
us doing this we were all crying we're
all kind of cuddling each other
strangers you know four to eight hours
ago and it was one of the most impactful
um kind of moments of my life to have
that experience i was like i need to go
down this breath work route now because
there's something going on here but then
the more i found out about it the more i
found about patrick's work and and uh dr
bliss of ranch's work and all these
people i've had on my podcast i was like
i've got to get our foundations right
before we start messing with some of
this stuff because it can be very
profound but actually from audience
stress situation let's let's let's get
the functionality sorted so you decided
to quit your corporate job and get into
breath work like
what happened next time so uh some i'm
awake in that or something weird going
on um next thing i did was i um i walked
across the camino so you can do a walk
across spain i think you know that so i
did that for 33 days again by myself
i've never done these things i went by
myself made friends with a fantastic
group of people and we just walked every
day 10 12 hours just walking in sunshine
you were the tribe of people
it's ticking a lot of the boxes of what
nature intended us to have um and then
after that i went to see tony robbins
with 13 000 other people um and we're
doing this uh process called the dickens
um and he basically is getting you to
this point where you're thinking if what
are all the problems i think i've got in
my life what if i don't change them
where would i be in five years now let's
extend that to ten years if i don't make
change
again people are crying there's thirteen
thousand people in the room crying oh
making these these noises this is like
day three of us is retreat um i was like
i need to quit my job i need to quit my
job i always wanted to go traveling
around the world i never did it so this
was 2018 and then me my girlfriend we
handed a notice in that week sold the
car sold the bed and then we took a year
off and went i went traveling indonesia
israel um
borneo
a load of places in that that way
wonderful barley um and that whole time
i'd already made a couple of women hof
breathing exercises on youtube
and it was only because nothing existed
at the time and my background uh before
the corporate world i did video
production at university so i know how
to edit and i know how to film and all
that sort of stuff and these videos
started doing really well and i'm in
bali and i've got a bit of time and i
thought okay i'll start looking at five
and start getting voice artists and all
that sort of stuff and the channel just
just keeps growing and keeps growing um
and then when the pandemic really kicked
in almost two years ago now i was like
i've got a good feeling for this but i
don't really understand any of the
science of it and so that's when i
learned the oxygen advantage uh through
patrick he trained me um and then he he
had this manuscript for this book called
breath by a guy called james nestor and
he said this is the best book i've ever
read on breathing and this is patrick
mcewan saying this he's a bit of a
godfather of breathing less than i need
so very cheekily i emailed his publicist
said would you be interested in having a
conversation with me on zoom i've got a
really decent breath channel now it
might be good to sell the book and she's
like yeah bring him on um and that was
the first podcast and he was on joe
rogan the week after and so then it kind
of exploded but it what it taught me was
uh you need to learn some of the science
now because you've got all this like
breathe more than you need you've got
some wonderful feelings and sensations
but it seems like there's thousands of
breathing exercises out there we need to
understand some of that so that was that
was kind of where i got to and by the
way i can demystify breath work again in
a simple way for you so we hear about
all these different breathing exercises
but we already know it's breathe more
breathe less
if we dug that down a little more it's
mouth or nose
there's an inhale there's a hole at the
top of the inhale there's an exhale
there's a top there's a hole at the the
exhale and then there's the pace so
there's kind of seven key variables to
any breathing exercise and that's why i
like to call it breath play because we
can kind of go with a long inhale and a
slow exhale and we can just mess about
with those sort of things triangle
breathing so in out and hold or box
breathing in hold out hold and so
again breath work can seem quite
daunting at first but really it's it's
seven different variables that can make
a huge change and the exciting thing
i've always found about breath work
who's i'm so passionate about it is
how you breathe affects how you think
and feel
and we know that we have the ability to
consciously change how we breathe so we
can affect how we think and feel
okay i have a
that's such a great story this is
fantastic stuff i have i have a few
different things a few different like
points i want to dive into the first one
is a bit of a tangent um you're at this
tony robbins retreat yes a what prompted
you to go to a tony robbins retreat
because most people like in our
generation would think it's a bit
woo-woo and stuff and it seems more for
the i don't know our parents generation
possibly
i don't know
maybe have the wrong idea of tony
robbins but
you know as much as i kind of appreciate
and admire the guy
just the the vibe that people my age
seem to have of him is like oh you know
fake guru kind of vibes yeah yeah um i
don't know how to do that so what
prompted you to go in that retreat and
what was that experience like when you
decided to quit your job if you could
like so so uh i watched i am not your
guru oh i've heard really good things
about that so good because i i know tony
robbins from shallow hal and you know
he's he's uh have you seen charlotte
howard jack black no so jack black and
um oh who's the actress uh gwyneth
paltrow okay and i won't ruin the story
oh it's 20 years old anyway he's in the
elevator and he hypnotises jack black to
see her as being more beautiful than she
she might be physically in the in the
story um and so i was like who's this
guy and then i saw the the the
documentary it had me in tears i was
like oh my god when you start to look at
stories of people and the personal
transformation that blew me away then my
best friend who i met on the wim hof
retreat been best friends now for five
years um he went there and said it it uh
profoundly changed his life and so i was
like i've got this kind of feedback from
the how i'm feeling watching the
documentary and what my best friend
saying did my own research like i need
to go and i need to go and do this it
was just a bit like with the wim hof and
the camino there was kind of this uh
you've heard of the traffic light
systems how you brain your heart and
your guts feeling and if you've got a
challenge in your life you might say
okay let's do the traffic light system
my head's saying it's a night but my
heart saints yes my gut saints yes i've
got two greens one red it was kind of
this all over i feel like i just need to
go in and do this and it was wonderful
it was four days it was in london you're
exhausted you start at
11am and finish 11pm he's a beast he's
on stage and you know he's been doing
the same uh schtick for 40 years now 30
years he hasn't really changed if you
look at the the videos from the haters
um it's the same sort of stuff but it
really does work and so i learned so
much yeah what's it like what does the
tony robbins retreat look like so you
you go into a festival let's see like
describe it so you go into the excel
center it's thirteen thousand people in
seats and then i was like i am not gonna
get up on my i'm not gonna be dancing
i'm not a dancer you know i am very um
what do you call it uh uh you know titan
i'm not going to be doing this also 15
minutes like come on totally and we're
all up on our feet um and the energy in
the room i don't know how he does it
there's a combination of music intensity
you kind of know who he is and then
you're just you're just in this kind of
i guess hypnotized state for four days
uh where he's like getting you to break
off into little groups and so right
let's talk about a time where you
struggled with so-and-so and then make
some notes in you in your workbook and
you don't really get a break you're
going for like he's like you need to
play full out with me now for the next
four days can you do it you can do four
days can't you you know we can do
anything for four days so he gets you in
this top i would highly recommend it
it's like
i need to i need to do one of these now
i mean he does it on um zoom i did that
one
last year
it's good but it's it's not the same i
guess it's not the same as in person
yeah it's incredible in person so i left
there just buzzed and and it's almost a
bit too much because like i need to
change my whole life you know i need to
tell everybody about what i've been
through but they're not going to know
because i've not had the four days with
tony and that sort of thing and so um
you know i give my notice but i did it
in a
smarter way i said look it was that was
march i'm going to leave in december i'm
going to give you i've been with the
company 14 years so i'm going to give
you like you know seven eight months
notice but i will be leaving at the end
of the year and want this to be an
official resignation because if you
don't take it i'll still be here another
14 years and it was it was the best
decision because um everything that you
think is a fear of leaving your job you
say well what's the worst that's going
to happen i might not get another job
you're going to get another job and so i
got another job when i needed to and it
was absolutely fine so what was it about
the
event that made you decide that you
needed to quit your job it was it was
the dickens process i mean there's a
combination of things you're doing but
it is this uh visualization exercise
where
you've kind of been thinking for the
last couple days about what are my
limiting beliefs what's stopping me from
moving forward where would i really want
to be if i had no fear so if i had no
fear what was it i would want to do
right now well why am i not doing those
things and you really think about it and
the process is about
two hours long so two hours of like
guided visualization and it's like how
would you feel if you're in this place
of lack in five years and ten years what
noise would you make if you were that
person and you're like oh and everyone's
doing it so it's kind of feeding off
each other and it's like okay and he's
like step into this you know bright
light imagine what it's like now if you
removed those fears and you did what you
really wanted to do and by the way i'm
butchering this from like a few years
ago but it you do it and then you make
some commitments like okay so what am i
going to do next and my first one was
quit my job you know and so
and it just it just felt like the right
thing to do well okay
i really need to try one of these so the
his his team actually got in touch with
us last year when he was doing a zoom
thing and being like hey do you want to
do the zoom thing i was like oh no i
want to do in real life like i think
zoom wouldn't wouldn't be quite the same
experience
um but i have done some some of these
like visualize your ideal future type
stuff like guided meditation type things
for like 10 minutes at a time and i
always feel damn that was really useful
i should do this more often so just the
thought of actually
you know being committed to
doing this sort of stuff for a few days
or a few hours i imagine would be quite
quite useful yeah and it's the stuff
that we just tend not to do like really
think about where do i actually want to
be in five years time like what are the
things holding me back like
like when when day to day life is going
along you just don't think in those
terms
um
as as a person you are and the things
that you talk about this is right up
your street it is i know he's been
around for years but he's kept current
so
and he always adds extra value he's a
master of adding extra value and so you
know getting to the end of i think day
one i can't remember day three and then
he was oh yeah my friends just come to
to do a little gig for you and then
pitbull turns up and does it like a
concert for you in the same place and i
wasn't a massive pitbull fan until then
but then he tells a story about how he
was coached by tony and what he did to
help his life and how he was in his
mom's car listen to tony robbins tapes
in the 90s and 80s and so he tells the
story then he starts doing and you're
like i've got a free concert out of this
as well so so you are in this four-day
bubble um it's really powerful it shifts
if you if you've got stuff that's kind
of bubbling under the surface it's going
to come through in that session yes by
the way tony robbins in breath work is
is fantastic so so tony robbins um what
i would say about him is he is
researching what's the best thing
in a specific modality
and so he does all sorts of stuff so
he's looking at kind of human psyche and
nlp and a lot of other things but he
also says that the quickest way to
change your state is to change the
physiology to move so he's very keen on
moving listening to music and changing
your state but he also has a good thing
about breath work so he's adopted the
wim hof method into that and he's got
people doing a bit of that he does some
priming in the morning where he's doing
kind of breath of fire stuff but he also
um
really loves a guy called dan brule who
is the godfather i think of of breath
work he's 40 years in now started as an
emt i had him on the podcast at my end
and what he doesn't know about breath
work isn't isn't worth knowing but what
he antonio wrote the full word to his
book and tony robbins has a quote
something like um if you can harness the
power of your breath you can change
yourself physically mentally and
spiritually and i think that's just it's
a really lovely summary of his
interpretation of what you can do with
this very benign thing of breathing in
and out you know it's this weird thing
we don't really think about but when you
start getting under the surface and
playing with it it can have big changes
in your life awesome so yeah this tony
robbins experience made you decide quit
the job and then let's explore this
breath work stuff more started the
youtube channel things started going
well pandemic happens you've got the
podcast you have all these big people
who are into breath work and have
researched it and doctors and professors
and stuff on the podcast
and now here we are yeah trying to talk
about yeah breath work um one of the
other things that you said which i found
interesting was
you said that breath work or breathing
or changing the way you breathe has the
potential to change how you think what's
the deal with that like so far we've
talked about kind of oxygen dissociation
curves and stuff we haven't really
touched on the mental effects of
breathing what's yeah what's going on
there so there was a study in mice and
and what it was really with the
terminology they used but they said
there's some neurons in the brain that
spy on the way we breathe and so there's
this thing around how i breathe does
affect it sends signals so i i was
trying to think i was trying to
rationalize things maybe you're trapped
under a tree and you can't breathe
properly or someone scared you um but
suddenly the way that you're breathing
is bi-directional so if i'm stressed my
breathing is going to change but if i
breathe in a stressful state it's going
to send signals that i'm i'm stressed
and so when i interviewed dr bliss of
ranic who who trains ufc fighters and
swat teams in america how to breathe
properly um i said
how do we what i said is a chicken leg
here what comes first does does
dysfunctional breathing cause stress and
anxiety or distress and anxiety causes
functional breathing and her response is
the best because i don't care let's fix
the breathing we know we can fix the
breathing so let's fix the breathing and
if there's still an issue afterwards
then let's look at what that is and so
that to me was this thing around okay
how we're breathing is affecting how
we're thinking and feeling so for
example if you extend your exhale then
back to that breath play thing what
you're kind of doing there sending a
signal to your brain say everything's
okay we're okay we're safe because if
you're running from a tiger you're not
slowly nasal breathing if you picture
what that person looks like they're
probably panic breathing so a slow
exhale through the nose all the mouth
actually
just sends some signals everything's
okay and so by doing that it can
actually lower blood pressure make you
feel calmer and more relaxed and so
there's some breathing exercises around
sleep and uh just doing some
and then breathing in counting to four
holding for seven and breathing out for
eight and just that release just saying
everything's okay it can change how you
you think now if you do win hot
breathing and you stress yourself out
that's going to make a different change
to your brain it's going to make your
brain feel
there's a problem here we're
hyperventilating um and that's going to
have its own uh effects on your thinking
and feeling but if we go back to the
functional side of stuff
um if we are depriving our
wonderful body of oxygen because we've
blown off too much co2 that is also
going to affect it because it's
affecting how much blood and rich oxygen
is getting to you your brain as well
because you're out of balance so it
sounds like the effects
on the brain are more like
breathing less
slight breathing more deeply gets you
into this relaxed calm state
and
it's it it it it sounds like it ties in
with that stuff that genuinely the way
that you move your body
does
relate to the way that your brain and
your body kind of feels
[Music]
in a way like i know
some people used to
they i think like we came across like
james lang theory of emotion which was
that
you know we don't smile because we're
happy we're happy because we're smiling
words to that effect and people like
quibble about this in the in the
scientific community of like oh but like
the evidence isn't quite there and if
you look at this meta-analysis
but i think
you take taking all that aside
i guess you know people's actual lived
experience of you know when you do for
example a mindfulness thing or like a
yoga thing or like a breathing thing
it does change the way that you feel and
maybe the scientific study about exactly
what what fmri scanner is showing is
doing in the brain while you're doing
breath work maybe that's a bit equivocal
but who cares like i think
my view on this stuff is that like or if
it works then i'm not gonna quibble with
it too much
and there's a good quote i came across
in
an article i was reading about
stretching
which is that often
scientific
um evidence lags behind best practices
and i think on the breathing front like
given that breathing meditation these
sorts of things have been part of
traditions for thousands of years
the scientific method may not have yet
caught up with that um
that's my kind of very very rough read
on it um i guess you would know you've
interviewed doctors and stuff like
is the science behind all this stuff
like
actually pretty legit and it's just not
not very well known or yeah i mean
there's plenty of studies um about all
different things to do with breathing um
but what somebody said to me once was um
you know breath work people aren't very
rich people and so you know to get a
study done um is harder i guess than
some other things like meditation but
breath work is
i see it's like the new yoga so yoga i
don't know 30 years ago probably wasn't
mainstay like it is now breathwork seems
to be that thing in part due to james
nestor's best-selling book has really
helped um but it's this thing that's now
gaining momentum and with that what i
think you'll see is a lot more
scientific study but you know i've had
um i've had a number of doctors on um dr
catwoman haven't released his podcast
yet he's at the boston children's
hospital um and he talked passionately
and
about um mouth breathing in children
about the dangers of mouth breathing
about all the you know things that can
be fixed so easily if we just shot our
mouths um and you know he's a doctor
that's seen on the front line um every
single day um and yeah a whole host of
other kind of professionals that's the
the benefit i guess like what you do
with uh kind of your niche is um you get
to spend time picking the brains of
these people and you start to see
patterns and so that for me was the
thing of oh they all keep talking about
functional breathing and how it's an
important baseline to get that right and
so i've had some i've had like a
wonderful beautiful humanon from the
holotropic institute and people loved
her you know she talked about all the
healing uh powers of of hyperventilation
um but that to me seems secondary to the
let's get the functional breathing right
functional breathing as in are those 25
000 breaths that we take rather than the
one-off breathing exercises
exactly yeah okay at this point i'm sold
on the mouth breathing thing oh sorry no
the nose breathing
uh what's the deal with um
sort of i i i read in in in breath about
how
you know standard standard respirate you
know respiratory rate that we cite as
doctors is somewhere between 12 and 20.
and if someone has lower than 12 breaths
per minute they are hypoventilating uh
greater than 20 is hyperventilating and
these numbers are used in scales like
you know
could someone have sepsis you know the
sepsis criteria one of them is like a
breath rate greater than 30 greater than
20 depending on which thing you
you look at or also if someone is hypo
ventilating so breathing too little
potentially sign of opiate toxicity and
these other bad things that are
happening and so provided someone's
respiratory is between roughly 12 and
20. you're like cool this is fairly
normal
but then one thing i remember reading in
breath by james nestor was that oh [ __ ]
maybe 12 is actually too much uh well
yeah what's the what's the deal on how
often we should be yeah i think you know
um
that number seems to change from a
different paper to paper and person to
person but i think between 10 and 15 is
pretty good
once you start getting above 15 you're
getting into kind of dysfunctional
territory um and uh anders olsen who who
was part of that book with james nestor
says and he's worked with thousands of
of students i think he's seen people in
the 30s you know per minute in terms of
breath what there is there is something
known as the perfect breath um and
coherence breathing is down this route
and that's around 5.5 breaths a minute
so we talked about that but that isn't
how we should breathe all the time but
coherence breathing is very very really
cool um so i'm not an expert in this at
all but what's going on here have you
heard of entrainment
um if you put a load of metronomes a
load of metronomes together they sync up
do they yeah and so this happens with
around five other clocks and it's and i
think the guy originally thought oh it's
because the wind is is blowing them but
actually they were on the same piece of
wood and so there's small vibrations and
they sync up through that so you go on
youtube now i think someone's got like
100 metronomes and it shows them all
thinking because they're all on like a
wobbly ball but anyway um what that's
showing is when one thing starts to
happen it kind of has an effect on other
things when you're breathing at 5.5
breaths a minute or 5.5 in 5.5 out
you uh are using your diaphragm which
you haven't spoken about yet you're
breathing at a nice slow rate the inhale
um is uh uh coming in and then you're
going out and that's pumping the heart
we're massaging the heart with the
diaphragm
and then what that's doing is when you
breathe out and you massaging the heart
the diaphragm moves back up again so so
the blood's going around your body at a
rate now that you're pumping it because
you're going a nice slow rate you're not
breathing fast you're slowing it all
down
and
apparently what is happening is then the
signals are going from your heart to
your brain and it's all becoming in sync
and so there's a improvement of heart
rate variability there and more
relaxation
and so the coherence people are
fascinating people there's a whole other
sub-sect of of breathing but that's
where it comes back to this 5.5 seconds
and i think james and lester spoke about
uh rose rosary beads and people praying
and they would be kind of saying the
lord's prayer and breathing and not
nasal breathing but they were slowing
their breathing down as they were like
talking about the lord's prayer and i
think it's in other religions as well so
there are some health benefits to
slowing it right down
one of them is by slowing your breathing
right down uh you are starting to build
up your co2 levels and by building your
co2 levels a little bit uh you're gonna
start adjusting your sensitivity to co2
as well and so if your co2 sensitivity
is is higher or you know normal let's
say you're going to breathe at a slower
rate but if your co2 levels low because
your mouth breathing you're going to
breathe at a faster rate so some
exercises which we'll jump into in a bit
are all about let's just slow our
breathing down let's get used to that
feeling of air hunger because by doing
so it's a bit like going to the gym and
lifting that weight we're training
ourselves to breathe at a slower rate
okay
cool um we've mentioned the diaphragm a
few times
um
i've had a few singing lessons which to
my annoyance often focused on breathing
i was like come on i want to get to the
good stuff they were like bro there was
no good stuff until until you saw the
breathing thing out but i've never done
them for long enough to actually have
quote sorted the breathing thing out uh
and i always wanted to dive into
actually singing songs and and all that
crap um but
um they were often focused on kind of so
sort of people describe it in different
ways like breathe some some people say
breathe into the tummy and then other
people say oh no breathing into the
abdomen is like not how you should be
thinking about it it's not about pushing
your tummy out instead it's about using
your diaphragm
then some people say well the diaphragm
is under the control of the phrenic
nerve or something which is a
is not under conscious control and
therefore like how can you actively
choose to breathe through the diaphragm
and then i went on a rabbit hole on
youtube about this and it seems like
everyone's got an opinion yeah about
whether you should be breathing into
your tummy or not into your tummy or
into the base of your lungs and not into
the base of your lungs
i guess the question is how should we be
okay
so um uh dr chatterjee wrote a really uh
good book about stress and then he
talked about diaphragm he says when
we're when we're unconsciously breathing
the diaphragm is moving about one
centimeter but when we consciously focus
on belly breathing let's say we can move
it up to 10 centimeters
now we've talked a lot about the nose
but when it comes to
gas exchange the blood is at the lower
part of our our lungs and that's where
the really cool gas exchange happens the
best gas exchange and obviously we use
the nose because we want the
vasodilation of the nasal nitric oxide
but also what's happening is when we uh
if our belly's locked let's just say i
put a band around this now and i can't
move it then i might become what's known
as an upper chest breather so if you
take a big breath in then your chest
goes up you've got all these extra
muscles which can be used again a bit
like an emergency mouth breath we can we
do all this and you know my channel's
called take a deep breath and if you
said to nine out of ten people how did
you take a deep breath in yeah but
actually you can take a deep breath in
slowly using your nose and using your
belly so instead you'd be
i always feel conscious when i do this
because the belly comes out and i'm like
oh why am i so fat so
so by the way uh one of the biggest
things i've struggled with in my life is
is what's known as gut sucking which is
bloody terrible for you so i i started
working in pub kitchens when i was
really like young like 14 15. i had free
access to chips and fries the whole time
and so easily started to get a bit of a
belly doing that and so i would suck it
in it was only when i um had the
conversation with dr bliss vranich where
she's like yeah that you shouldn't be
sucking your belly and that's that's
really bad that's a common trait people
have because you are effectively
stopping your diaphragm from moving
which means you can't get a full gas
exchange all this is locked your
diaphragm is this dome shaped muscle
that goes all the way around the back so
if you start here and you start working
your fingers around the diaphragm is
bloody huge it goes all the way right
around the back you know this huge thing
on the biggest muscles
and um that muscle is a stabilization
muscle so um it's linked to uh poor
lower back problems
it's linked to your digestion
and so um you know if you're using your
diaphragm it's kind of massaging
everything you'll know as a doctor
there's not a lot of space in here if
you look at what's inside everything's
pretty compressed and so the extra work
of the diaphragm is kind of massaging
everything the tummy all that sort of
stuff and so if it's locked again we are
not being that uh natural uh you know uh
ancestor with a with a chimpanzee with
the kind of coke kind of bent over and
so we want to be able to use diaphragm
i've got some exercises i can show you
around how we kind of open it all up and
stuff um and it's conscious practice but
i also believe it's education as well
because if you don't know the diaphragm
is good for you in the nose it's good
for you then why would you why would you
use it but now that people listen to
this and you understand what the why and
we're going to do the how that's how you
can make a significant shift in your
life
okay
so i shouldn't be worried about my belly
coming up while i'm breathing let it
come out yeah let it come out we'll do
some exercises just uh just to kind of
release that but yeah we
we uh we need to release the belly so
when you say suck your gut in what does
do you mean like tense your abs yeah so
so literally you could be like if i in
the photograph i'd be like oh i need to
suck the tummy in for that and you might
be you might be like that all day
there'll be sometimes i mean i've done a
lot of work on this over the last couple
of years but there'll be some times that
i'll be
you know i use i use a a saw in a spa
where i where i am and i was speaking to
a friend the other day and suddenly i
felt myself stuck my stomach turned me
in yeah i was like oh no come on you
know that's bad for you um and so i have
to kind of just consciously remind
myself to kind of release it um but yeah
you by doing that you're not giving your
diaphragm the space to move properly and
so by doing that you're no longer an
efficient functional breather you're
being dysfunctional but in a different
way to what's going on here because
you're not getting the air into the
lower lungs and not doing a good
transfer got it
okay
should we dive into some exercises let's
do it let's do it just one last thing on
on breathing i think it's important is
the efficiency and the rate of breathing
okay
so um in the simplest way possible if
you do my maths are terrible but if you
do uh 12 breaths a minute
and your tidal volume which is the
amount of air you take in is half a
liter
yeah so that's that's like 12 liters
yeah all right six months six years a
minute yeah
six liters now if i was to double my
tidal volume to a liter of air i would
only need to take six breaths in that
same minute
the extra bonuses because that air is in
your lungs for a little bit longer got a
bit more time to do the transfer so by
slowing our breathing down we become
more efficient i think it's 20 more
oxygen is absorbed through each of those
breaths so i've now just suddenly taken
half the amount of breaths as you and
more oxygen is able to be absorbed into
my body so pace is so important to
slowing everything down and again this
is where education comes in because you
can slow your breathing down build up
your tolerance to co2 and your general
breath permit it will start to slow down
as well okay
cool so how do we do this okay
so how's the how's the the nose first of
all is it is it open but blocked it
feels a bit blocked yeah but it always
feels a bit blocked i've been
consciously trying to breathe through
the nose for the conversation but i've
i'll look at the footage afterwards i'll
see how much of it was actually i'm not
hanging open you're cursed by the way
now because you'll be looking at
everyone's mouth breathing sounds
yeah um have you got a phone or
something to hand yes so so a bit gross
but bit funny you could just blow onto
it you can see like which nostril is
kind of what the airflow flows like so
if you just put the phone here like this
and then just kind of breathe onto it
get an idea of what you kind of breath
for maybe one nostril's a bit more open
than the other i don't see anything at
all let me take it out of the case
so for people listening in what i'm
doing is i'm holding up my phone
parallel to the floor
underneath my nostrils and blowing onto
it
yeah definitely more from this one okay
so one's one's a bit more open the other
so it's a feedback mechanism just to see
kind of what's going on i mean you can
sometimes just cap a nostril and
see which one's open and we have what's
known as arousals with our nostrils so
so sometimes one will be more open the
other and they'll take it in turns to
kind of open and close yeah this one's
right one's definitely much more than
the other one and there's some
interesting studies around again i would
do yoga years ago i think this is a
waste of time alternate nostril
breathing there's some studies and james
lester references these if you're
breathing through the left nostril it's
more of a cool and carbon effect if you
breathe through the right nostril it's
more creative energy effect and that
sounds like proper proper woo-woo but
they've done studies where they've kind
of blocked somebody's nostril up and
then just tests with them um so anyway
there's some cool stuff with the
nostrils so what one do let's um do you
want to unblock your nose first sure
so it
works about 50 times if you're already
breathing quite well then you might not
feel it but we'll do it now maybe we can
cut it if it doesn't work but so what i
want you to do is take in a second take
a normal breath in and a normal breath
out and i'm going to capture those i'm
going to just shake the head and the
body and the reason i'm doing that just
create a bit more co2
um and what i want to do there is do a
fairly strong breath hold okay um and
then when your this is important thing
when you're finished you want to breathe
back in through the nose because you've
harnessed some nasal nitric oxide there
so we want to make sure we capture that
because it's the vasodilator so in out
hold shake as long as you can um don't
do this if you're pregnant if you've got
epilepsy or high blood pressure it's
quite a strong breath hold um and what
we'll do that is just going to start to
increase the co2 in your body and start
to open everything up a little bit so
we'll do we'll do you need to about five
times on this so we'll do a little bit
and see how okay
so normal breathing normal breath in
normal breath out cap your lows
shake your head
keep shaking shake your whole body it's
good to feel silly look silly
have a little dance keep holding and as
you're doing this just know
you're full of oxygen and so when that
urgency to breathe comes it doesn't want
to be a very stressful breath but when
you feel the right time to breathe
you're going to breathe back in
through your nose
you're going to haunt all that beautiful
nasal nitric oxide
and then back out through the nose
so it may have started may not yet we're
going to just breathe normally now
through those just for the next 20 30
seconds we're going to go for a second
round and then just the air hunger was
that what how would you have described
how you felt during the last few seconds
was it quite
yeah quite unpleasant okay so just keep
breathing through your nose
settling the breath again
and when you're ready now we're gonna do
a normal breath in through the nose a
normal breath out through the nose
you're gonna cap your nose i'm gonna
shake
that's
boogie
and again you know that urgency to
breathe is going to come up and that's a
good thing because the co2 is rising in
your body
just to the point where you've got a you
know a medium to strong air hunger
keep going know that you're full of
oxygen
and we'll just keep breathing for a
second
now we're only two in to probably five
but is there any notable difference as
yet does it still feel about the same or
i think this the unblocked nostril has
become more unblocked okay good we'll do
one more and we'll see how that's going
but about five is about optimal for this
and a wonderful thing to do before bed
it's an exercise it's going to help open
things up before you put your mouth tape
on okay so when you're all ready in your
own time you're going to breathe back in
through the nose and out through the
nose you're going to cap your nose and
we're going to shake
keep going keep shaking keep going
getting a real insight to you as a
dancer at a wedding i think here
right now the co2 levels are really
starting to to go a bit higher in the
body no nothing dangerous here we're
just you know slowly holding our breath
not to the point of passing out just
purely a point where we can start to
open up on those a little bit
yeah we're feeling a little bit maybe a
little bit more open yeah yeah good yeah
yeah definitely on this nostril good
good and you know you can do that three
six times just a good way to get you
started so um what i want us to do then
first is um you can do this with your
eyes open or closed this one's called
breath awareness okay so i take my right
hand onto my belly uh right hand belly
yep and left hand on to my heart left to
left hand heart you want to sit up nice
and straight
and this is the maybe the most difficult
exercise alley because what i want to do
is do nothing i just want you to focus
on how your breathiness
and it might be very hard to do first of
all because you're going to want to
start to change things
but really the whole point here is just
to check in
with your breathing
and the reason for your hands
where they are because not only will you
get to sense it through your nostrils
you'll also get to sense how your hands
are moving
so your belly hand is that moving much
is that staying the same same with the
chest
so it's just
breath awareness could be arguably the
most important because we need to know
how we're breathing first so we can get
under the hood and start to make some
changes
and as you sit there and breathe not
really trying to change anything at all
just paying attention
to the sound or the feeling of the air
that comes in through your nose
and out through your nose
and how your hands are moving
and avoiding that temptation to to
change anything
just breathing in through the nose
and out through the nose
it could be quite powerful this because
you're checking in with yourself here
it's a form of active meditation because
not only we're just trying to clear our
thoughts we're actively focusing on
something but something we don't really
want to change just to just to pay
attention to
so just continue now breathing in
through the nose
and out through the nose
and when you're ready you can open your
eyes again
and so the benefit of that exercise is
just to get a sense of how you are
feeling
and as you go through the steps of
practicing different breathing exercises
that becomes a useful tool to kind of
check in with yourself because you might
have found right then oh my hand didn't
really really move much on the belly it
was quite static or i could feel my
chest was moving quite high or i felt
like i was breathing quite fast on there
and so it's just it's just a check-in
and then something you can journal about
and come back to
so what i want to do now is do a little
bit of box breathing with you okay and
the reason for this is before we go into
some of the other exercises let's just
slow everything down navy seals use this
uh exercise because uh by slowing
everything down we might be in a better
state to make a decision as opposed to
being
frantically breathing panic breathing
trying to make decisions let's just slow
everything down so what i'll do i'll
just guide you through a little bit of
box breathing just a couple of rounds so
i'm going to use the nose for this so
we're going to breathe in through the
nose for four
three
two
one and hold four
three
two
one and out through the nose four
three two one and hold four three
two
one and in through the nose four
three
two one and hold four three
two
one and out through the nose four
three
two one and hold four three two one
let's just slow it down slightly now in
through the nose five four
three
two
one
hold five
four three
two one out through the nose five
four three
two one and hold five
four three two one and go back to normal
nasal breathing now when we slowed it
down was there any challenge with that
or was it i could do five i could do
maybe even six or seven so yes that's
great yeah good okay
so what i want to move on to now is um
sorry chaos of course what's the point
of these breathing exercises okay so uh
the breath awareness is to check in okay
with the body yeah the the uh box
breathing is just slowing us down so
you're just getting a bit of control now
so starting to get under the hood and
play with it okay and so by breathing at
a slower rate it comes back to
increasing your levels of co2 if i'm in
a if i feel like i'm in a stressful
situation or yeah if you've come out of
a meeting and you know your boss has
been shouting at you whatever you're
just in that panic state you can check
in with yourself you can then do box
breathing just to slow everything down
and by slowing everything down you're
thinking clearer and you can move
forward and make a decision nice yeah
okay cool so what i'd like us to do now
is let's start to feel the airflow
because this is a really cool exercise
so what you do is you get the you get
your middle finger and where the middle
finger meets the hand you can just place
that on your on your nose like this
and as you're breathing through your
nose
hope you've not had anything smelly on
your hands um what you'll find is the
airflow should start to hit the hand
yeah so what i'm going to do now i'm
going to guide you through slowing this
down so just keep that hand there by the
way you can also do it like this
as a feather breath i don't think it
looks very good from a pr point of view
to be doing that so i like to do it this
way um and so uh what you're doing here
is you're feeling the air as it's
hitting your hand and so we're gonna
start to slow that down now early so
what i want you to do you can you can
stay in the position you're in you can
keep your eyes open or closed just
before we start to play with it get a
sense of what that air feels like maybe
it's stronger on one nostril or the
other
um maybe the intensity is quite hard
just try and remember if you can what
that is because we're going to start
slow it down and what i'd like to use as
an analogy is one of those old car
stereos with the winding knob that you
can use to turn the volume down and what
i want us to do now is let's just start
to turn that volume down and what that
means for you is we're going to reduce
the airflow maybe just a couple of
percent to start off with
can we make the air
flow
quieter more gently and smoother as we
breathe in through the nose
and breathe out through the nose i can
already hear a quieter breath from you
now it was quite loud before and that
was quite it's fantastic so we're just
slowing it down
and as you start to do this breathing in
through the nose and breathing out
through the nose
the levels of co2 in your body are going
to rise slightly and you're going to
feel what's known as an air hunger
and that's good that's what we want to
do here now a bit like when we did the
breath holds before to unblock your nose
that would be classed as a strong air
hunger
we don't want to do that we want to
probably have a medium air hunger here
you know we're not trying to get to that
point where we're desperate but i would
like you to get to the point where you
want to start to take a bit of a bigger
breath but you're choosing not to you're
choosing to keep it slow so we're
breathing in through the nose and out
through the nose and the airflow is nice
and gentle on the hands now just give me
a nod is it gentle than it was at the
start of the exercise good okay now if
you can because this first time you've
done this i imagine let's just take that
radio knob and let's just turn it down
another couple of percent can we go a
little bit more could we go to a
slightly lower uh inhaler and a slightly
slower exhale slightly a little bit more
of airflow going back and forth
and again you're getting this wonderful
feedback of what's hitting your hand so
you get to feel the air but you're also
getting to feel it in your body the
feeling of air hunger
breathing in through the nose
and breathing out through the nose
and then when you're ready you can move
your hand and you can go back to normal
normal nasal breathing
how was that exercise for you
yeah i realized that sort of
subconsciously
i was like making noise while i was
breathing yeah and probably wasn't
necessary yeah
yeah when i was i i did yoga and barley
for a month and i would make the loudest
noise possible because i wanted the yoga
structure i was really suffering and
then i only realized after no no slow
nasal breathing is the game here is the
way forward so yeah just what we're
doing here we're just playing with some
different tools some free tools that can
get us out of our head and get us to
feel what's going on with our breathing
now an exercise like that you could do
that for 10 or 15 minutes in the morning
and the evening and by creating that air
hung on a consistent daily basis you're
going to be in a position where you're
going to start to raise your tolerance
to co2 and so i did that and it took me
about six weeks to get my breath hold
from about 14 seconds to about 30 which
is a good way and so with all of these
things like anything in life
consistencies okay that's the thing that
we we absolutely want to be doing
what i want to focus on now is a bit of
the abdomen breathing so so you talked
about belly breathing um you know how
best to do it there's there is a lot of
different ways of doing it but first of
all i like to think about the rib cage
because uh people talk about can you
improve lung capacity yeah um and if you
think about those
those
sacks those bags just hanging in the rib
cage well they're kind of constricted by
everything that's going on you know if
the diaphragm is not moving and the ribs
are locked then actually your lung
capacity is going to be reduced and
actually if we can open all that up then
it can make some differences so what we
need to do here is we want to start
opening things up so this is it's a bit
of a breathe necklace but a bit of
movement and by the way this is very
accessible so i'm very very very tight
um just naturally i think and so this is
an exercise that pretty much anyone can
do we can do some crazy yoga with adrian
and you know we can do handstands but in
this it's just about opening things up a
little bit so
the first exercise is called picking
apples and what we're going to do is
we're going to put our hand up in the
air and as we do we're going to breathe
in and we're going to grab an apple from
the top and so we're breathing in
grabbing the apple
stretching all of this all of the
intercostal muscles here that's sitting
between the ribs and we're just going to
open them up a little bit and grab the
apple and the good thing is we can slow
the breathing down same time so we're
going to go in
and i can emphasize that exercise but
actually it does feel quite nice to go
so go in again
that's good go the other arm
in pick an apple
nice big stretch and down
and there's two apples let's go with
both hands now
and we can really stretch the ribs on
both sides and it's your first time
don't push it and
back down again let's do one more both
hands in here
it just feels good to get your hands up
above your head because i think we don't
do enough now let's add some twists to
this okay
this is a good chair for this so we face
forward too much these muscles need to
move so what we want to do is we're
going to take a
breath in through the nose and as we
breathe out we can grab the back and
we're going to do a twist and we're just
twisting all the intercostals and get a
nice twist in there almost like ringing
a tea towel out so we'll sit in
face forward breathing in now
i'm squeezing and twisting and squeezing
and twisting and squeezing and twisting
and then when you're ready you're going
to breathe back in through the nose and
face forward
i'll do one more that side
so here we go nice breath in and out
twisting and squeezing get that tea
towel nicely rang out get all that
dishwater out of that tea towel let's go
okay and face forward and breathing and
we want to balance things out so we'll
do the other side twice now as well so
in your own time you're going to breathe
in
and we're going to twist
keep twisting that's it
nice twist breathing out face forward
i'll do one more twist
and breathing out through the nose
and what that exercise doing you can do
apple picking for a few minutes you can
do twisting for a few minutes i always
like to feel like i'm a bit more loose
now than i'm doing that and so
we're just opening up all that kind of
cage a little bit because it doesn't get
the love it deserves though so now we've
got a bit more flexibility and again
that's a good exercise you could do
every day every other day
and what we want to do now is we're
going to do some mechanical focusing on
our belly breathing so
some people say you can breathe into the
back
you can breathe into the sides and if
you actually put your hands here on the
sides we're going to let our bellies go
a little bit now if you take a nice slow
breath in through the nose
you'll feel your hands start to move
apart and the reason this is a good
exercise to do is because yes belly
breathing is important but it's really a
360 breath everything is opening into
the back i heard that um at the start of
cover they stop putting patients on
their backs because they won't be able
to get a full breath and so we breathe
you know in a 360 way but i also think
it's useful to focus on the belly so i
like to imagine there's a little balloon
in the belly that's inflating
and what we're doing here is when we
breathe in through the nose
we're really focusing on everything
expanding outwards and then we breathe
back in again
the diaphragm comes back up into a nice
resting position
and just by focusing on the diaphragm it
already starts to move a little bit more
a bit like what dr chatterjee said in
his book you know one centimeter versus
10 centimeters is huge
and so we don't necessarily want to push
out as far as we can but just a normal
nice breath in
i want to try and keep the shoulders
where they are we might be used to being
shoulder breathers and if you look at
somebody that takes a big breath the
shoulder's moving we want to keep that
breath nice and low and we can also put
our hand back on the belly and one back
on the chest and this time now we can
focus on the belly moving out as we
breathe in
as we breathe back out the belly moves
in and the diaphragm moves up
breathing back in
and breathing back out
so those exercises i would say are
really useful as functional foundations
for people so what we've got there just
a quick reminder so we've got breath
awareness to check him
then we can do some box breathing to
slow things down then we can feel our
breath
then we can do some twisting to open
everything up and then finally we can
focus on our diaphragm and we can focus
on the belly breathing by using those
combinations now with the breath
awareness of the education that we've
got you can start to unpick what's
happened over the
centur decades for me in particular and
we can start to go back to the way
nature intended us to breathe which is
functionally which is efficiently which
is the way that we should be breathing
the way we used to breathe as children
but actually we lost it through chronic
stress poor posture
you know being indoors and being cramped
all day we can actually unpick some of
that and i've been through my own breath
journey i had lower back problems
they've much better i had ibs my whole
life my diaphragm was locked no surprise
i wasn't getting any massage in there
and so we can start to unpick some of
this um and if i can give a bit of a
plug um so i've just finished literally
yesterday a functional breathing
essentials master class it's a five-week
master class
and what that does is it takes
everything we've talked about here but
we go in much deeper into the what the
why in the house this be like a mini
master class and over those five weeks
i'll set you different homework
um you then get a week to practice it
you get to learn all about it there's
different things you can do you can
measure your breath scores all these
different things and at the end of the
five weeks you get a really deep
knowledge of being a functional
efficient breather and that's that's
live now and i'm uh i can do a
an alley 2022 22 discount on that so i
was thinking about that so um so i can
give you the code for that so anybody
that's watching this would be able to
get a discount and get cracking with
that course yeah we'll stick that in the
video description in the show notes
sweet this has been great interesting
intro introduction to the idea of breath
work i will continue taping my mouth
short because it seems to be good for
you
i will continue being somewhat trying to
be mindful of breathing through my nose
even if i don't feel like it because i
always feel like oh it feels a bit
blocked but yeah this this exercise is
quite useful and i'm very keen to attend
to tony robbins thing and also sort of
been i've been thinking about like oh i
should go to one of these wim hof things
for ages just haven't really gotten
around to it but
it will it will happen at some point um
and then we're doing an interview on
your podcast straight after this so
we'll put that in the video description
in the show note so people can check out
more if people are interested in that
sort of thing but yeah thank you very
much for coming on any uh recommended
resources for people who want to dive
into this topic a bit more yeah so
obviously i'm shamelessly plugging my
course but but also my breath cast i
don't know if that's an original name or
an unoriginal name but there's kind of
50 plus experts now been interviewed all
about wellness and breathing and that's
really been a big source of my breathing
education and so to have this time and
you can go and watch these on youtube or
listen to them on spotify um anybody who
wants to go deeper down the rabbit hole
of breath work you know most of the top
people are in there james nestors the
patrick mcewans
the doctor bliss of randishes um and a
whole host of other people so i really
recommend that as a good resource if you
want to go much deeper sick so and we'll
put a link to the breath cast podcast in
the video description of the show notes
as well alright so that's it for this
week's episode of deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye